the war effort starts here it's a long
and slow process as you can see they use
anything they can get their hands on
donated old clothes new clothes
materials straight from manufacturers
you know sheets pillowcases coats even
ladies tights as well absolutely vital
to try and make a pattern that is
unreadable by anything in the air this
is also a library as well it's actually
reopened such as the demand victor is
one of those who's volunteered and why
do you think it's so important for for
someone like you to get involved like
this
i think it's also important not only
from the patriotical point of view
because
our soldiers need it it can save lives
it's like a
psychological treatment you know
apartheid that is you or you stay at
home doing nothing just watching the
drastic tragic news or you are coming
here you are
communicating with people mixing with
people who have share the same views as
you and also doing this monotonous work
you protect your mental health
victor thank you very much indeed well
let's see upstairs then how the nets end
up
well it's actually mid brown and dark
brown they're short of right now and
that is because we're coming out of
winter of course the colors will change
as the seasons do a protracted battle
perhaps but here they weave onto
fishing nets all of that material that's
been cut up downstairs and the idea is
that this is unreadable from the sky
from russian drones or aircraft very
hard to see if it's handmade a pattern
that could be read if it was
manufactured
they used to make about 20 25 of these
nets a day but some of the volunteers
have gone back to work it's as if
they've tried to go back to their normal
life and now it's about five of these
nets a day specifically requested by
a battalion
the colors that they need and they will
send them on
[Music]